okay great thanks who wrote the title to
my talk actually okay fair enough it's a
little more ambitious tomorrow actually
do which will hopefully be an
introduction to the to the next three
talks so I did something similar last
semester when it was more computer
scientists and there the people knew
what tensor networks were but not what
critical exponents were so in this talk
all somewhat reversed the the priority
of what I'll start at the very beginning
from okay so since I'm going to be
drawing lots of tensors and tensor
networks let me just define the usual
notation and that's this Penrose
notation for how to contract things
together so let's say at a rank two
tensor which is just a matrix with two
indices here this is always gonna be
represented by a dot that's the tensor
and it's can have two legs
it's two indices so if I want to do a
higher rank tensor of course generalizes
and what's most convenient is I'm going
to represent Einstein summation so for
instance if I want to do matrix
multiplication law this as I JK and what
this means is if there's a leg
connecting two tensors it's implicitly
summed over so this gonna save a lot of
space
okay so arguably tensor networks
actually go back way before even what
Joel said which is just thinking about
statistical integrals or even path
integrals so let's consider one
dimensional stat mech so for instance a
small sort of thing I want to compute is
a partition function I have degrees of
freedom on sites which might be like a
Boltzmann spin here up or down and
addition function is a sum over
interactions here so this is a simple
example of a tensor network so the way I
can see this is by looking at the
transfer matrix so I take one element
here
see I Sigma J and this tensor T Sigma I
Sigma J there's just one component of
this Boltzmann weight this would just be
some two-by-two matrix so doing the
summation over all the configurations of
the spins is just if you want to
multiply these matrices together
so intensive networks are just a
generalization of this to higher
dimensionalities so for instance if I
want to do a a two-dimensional Ising
model each 2d they're not going to be
arranged into a two-dimensional grid
we're now the indices to be summed over
live on this two-dimensional grid of
links these tensors would be the weights
the Boltzmann weights of the two di
Simone so thinking about tensor networks
is an entirely new object in physics is
a little bit amusing because really it's
just a description of any path integral
or Boltzmann sum okay so the reason it
relates to States is the following let
me rather than considering just a
partition function I consider a
generating functional so for instance we
know if I want to know the generating
functional for the correlation functions
of magnetization I had this auxiliary
field here H and generalized my sum
also consider this external field here
so now I get a weight which depends on
the external field H so now the tensors
that form the tensor network actually
have three indices there is the Sigma
which are the icing weights but then in
each tensor there's also the H so this
is e to the negative beta Sigma I Sigma
I plus 1 so at a rank 3 tensor and this
partition function of the generating
functional so I have two types of
indices here there's these indices which
are summed over so if you call those the
virtual indices then there's the indices
left here which are left dangling
this would be the tensor network for a
generating function so to sort of change
history of it the idea is rather than
thinking this is a generating functional
for a one plus zero dimensional static
model I can actually think of this as a
wave function for a quantum ground state
so for instance suppose I have a spin
system like a Ising model which is now a
quantum spin system so my wave function
describe a configuration on some
one-dimensional lattice of spins and the
most general form it can take is going
to be some quantum mechanical amplitudes
so this is a large vector it's an a to
the L dimensional vector space
something like this this is psy and the
idea is I'm going to consider an on
thoughts for this for this wave function
just a falling tensor contraction now
the key thing that Joel alluded to is
what's special about ground states is
that their ground states of local
Hamiltonians so these amplitudes have a
very special structure and what
considering on thoughts which come from
contracting these tensors together is
precisely it captures the locality of
entanglement in these systems so this
particular on thoughts is called a
matrix product state and it can be
proven to work if we generalize this in
two ways so first we need to let the sum
Sigma not just run over se up and down
but in general the Sigma on each link is
give me in some high dimensional vector
space to we need to let these these
weights H Sigma Sigma rather than
thinking of them as being from some
simple Boltzmann model there just can be
arbitrary tensors so we're gonna treat
variational e so these two conditions
together define the matrix product state
variational class and what Hastings
showed was that for all gap to ground
states in one dimension they obey both
in area law and they have a matrix
product state form basically Gap States
so this has been the basis for DMR G is
basically a variational method for your
given Hamiltonian how could I optimize
the tenses of these song shots to best
approximate the ground state and
basically this proofs now that these
algorithms must always work so in some
sense massive field theories in one
dimension can all be solved numerically
using this exactly so what makes this
efficient is that Chi doesn't grow with
the size of the system if it obeys an
area law if there's a gap so to
generalize this to two dimensions it's
the naive and the same generalization we
made from going from a 1d Boltzmann some
to 2d one
so I have a 2d array of tensors and my
quantum system now lips on this 2d array
so now I have a dangling a dangling
index for each each site since it me my
so it's on stops it's called peps it's
rather interesting a lot less is known
about these two DS states so in in 1d we
can prove both exactly what states they
represent gap ground states and you can
prove that say measuring any observable
can be done efficiently in 2d we both
don't know what states take this form
we're not sure that all gap states do
and even if you had the wave function in
this form we don't in general know how
to efficiently compute sale a 1 or 2
point function so a lot of work that's
going on right now is to figure out in
2d can we actually use this as a basis
for efficient numerical algorithms or
not okay so now I want to understand the
entanglement properties of these tensor
networks so what's special about
entanglement and then yep so could it
say contract I don't think so I'm just
at what so are there any no restrictions
what's the condition
attitudes in the scale is relative
approximation will be the normal I don't
know if it's no no what precisely the
class would be in which it could be
efficiently done if you make
restrictions on the tensors preparing
each state and then do a measurement not
a single eight because you do a
projection
post-selection let's see what do you
mean in what direction are you thinking
of it is being unitary yes I mean if you
knew that looking at it this way it was
always sama trees then it could be
efficiently done but you can prove
basically no states can actually be put
in that form well so for instance if if
each of these tensors is an isometry in
some direction like this meaning that
contracting these three legs is an
isometry with respect to do these to you
could prove for instance that the
entanglement spectrum in such a state is
completely flat so it's not actually
generic consorts well in this particular
case if I made some by partition like
this all the Schmidt values would would
be the same yeah
yeah so it's also open question so in 1d
we know for instance is a certain
canonical form you can put the tensors
in like that they are isometry x' in a
certain direction it's not really known
in 2d there's a lot of gauge redundancy
here because you can insert various
resolutions of the identity not just on
bonds but on string like surfaces and
it's not really known how much you can
fix that redundancy
okay so let's calculate the entanglement
of a region in this sort of on sots this
is a simple picture we need if psy is a
wave function in some tensor product
hilbert space let's suppose and on sots
that it takes the form of just say a to
site matrix product state so I have
indices I left which runs over the full
Hilbert space on the left same on the
right and some bonds summing over here
and I'll assume as before that so it's
simple to see that if I want to look at
the reduced density matrix for the left
part of the system
the special thing about this on sots is
it the rank to the left is less than or
equal to Chi mistress because the number
of for instance the number of singular
values you could possibly have in this
matrix here is bounded by by Chi so that
one thing that follows from this is if
you look at the von Neumann entropy or
entanglement entropy for region on the
left it's also less than or equal to the
log of Chi so you can put an upper bound
but generically just want to actually be
saturated which will return to okay so
let's let's evaluate this for a peps
so suppose the sub-region I want to
consider it might be this block so let's
call this region X as six sites in it
and the rest of the system is is X bar
so we see that because of the form of
the tensor network it's actually just a
thickened version of this sort of wave
function here so I want to confide could
if I just contract these six tensors
together I get on sots of the following
form there's a big box here that has six
legs coming out this is I in region X
then I have some number of bonds exiting
through the boundary use it a Sigma's
and then this is a gigantic tensor which
actually has an infinite number of bonds
here for the tense of network for any to
buy partition always takes this form so
to bound the rank of the reduced density
matrix for X I can just apply this
formula here so let's say that each of
these Sigma's let's label these bonds by
K so this here is a collection of
indices Sigma K
the peps we're gonna have that the rank
of rho x is less than or equal to the
product over all the bonds which cross
the boundary of the dimension of the
bond there beside this is kite game so
it's dimension of the bond and it
follows from this that the entanglement
in region x less than equal to the sum
so for any region X these Ches run over
the boundary of the region so the amount
of intendment in a region is bounded by
the area of the perimeter rather than
the volume of it so this is the area law
so it's certainly only gonna capture
states which obey that so this is a very
very crude bound that's less than or
equal to and I think one of the key
problems is understanding how do I make
this this bound tighter what actually is
the entanglement in terms of the tensors
so let me say one sufficient condition
which I think will be talked about later
in the day in which this bound is
actually saturated so it reduces a
simple property of this particular map
here so sometimes this is called the
bulk boundary map so when I had this
region that I picked out there's two
types of indices there's the indices on
the virtual boundary and then there were
the physical indices okay so I can think
of this as a big box
Sigma sometimes this is called a the
bulk boundary tensor and if I think of
Sigma as the input and IX is the output
a is a map from boundary spins into the
hilbert space of the sub region X so a
sufficient condition for the tensor
network to actually saturate this bound
is if a is an isometry so you can show
that if a a dagger is 1 then the bound
is saturated so another way to put this
in English is it for each value of the
boundary spins I get a distinct
orthogonal state for the bulk then the
unsought saturates this entropy bound so
if we want to understand what the
Corrections are the more precise way of
putting it
it's ultimately get amount to
understanding what the properties of
this tensor are for for more generic
generic consults they're physical States
for you'd expect that to be saturated
well one could argue if you just take
large random tensors other systems whose
ground state is naturally large read
from Ted sources maybe they put it like
then I mean this is Brian's idea that
well let's see in 2d ok well one example
actually is the tort code actually
saturates this bounds except mod I'm on
the topological entanglement entropy
so I think most fixed-point
wavefunctions things with zero
correlation length modulo possible
topological correction are of this form
ok so now let's consider a state which
can't be put in this form so we said the
wave functions have to obey the area law
so we know one situation in which the
area law is actually violated is for 1d
critical systems so for a 1d critical
system we know that I take one D chain
X and X bar this has length L X
entanglement is gonna go like
she's a central charge so what this
tells you is if you tried to find a
matrix product state representation of
it the dimension that you need to use
would actually diverge with the length
of the system you tried to approximate
so the question is how can we fix the on
sots in order to be actually
accommodated log L violation of the area
law so let me do something that won't
work first because it starts giving us
an intuition for how the geometry of the
tensor network needs to sort of
geometric interpretation of the
entanglement so let me first fix it in
1d by starting with a matrix product
state and then just trying to add hidden
nodes so to speak so I'm gonna add more
layers up here so my spins only live at
the boundary here but I'm gonna add a
larger bulk here which gets integrated
over there summed over so now what i
want to understand is if i take on
thoughts like this what's the maximum
entanglement i can have in some
particular sub region
okay so suppose for instance I consider
X to be these two spins here so let's
entangling these two spins with the rest
of the system wants like that so I know
part for this particular cut the amount
of entanglement is gonna be bonded by
the bounded by the bond dimensions of
these four lines if I make it larger
wait cut it would be like this but the
interesting thing in this network is
that if I look at a region which is too
large this is not really the correct way
to do it what you actually want to do is
go up and then all of this is for free
and then I can come back down because
here I'm going to only cut six nodes
whereas if I kept going through here I'd
cut a linear number of Link's so if I
define I K to be the dimension of the
each of these links and I take a curve
gamma the collection of the links let me
define the length of the curve to be the
sum of K within gamma
so what I can do to bound the entropy in
a given region is find a gamma which
cuts out that region of minimal length
where length is defined by this
definition here so for this network if I
were to draw a graph of the bounds I get
s is the s max as a function of the
length of the region I pick out the
initial steps the shortest path stays
right near the edge and then the length
goes up linearly but then as soon as I
reach what the depth of this was it's
now quicker to just leave the tensor
Network and then it saturates this
maximum saturation here is related just
to the depth of the tensor network so
this was the simple case where it would
just be linear and saturate when all of
these links had the same weight you can
imagine in a more general situation
where the the links had different
weights it's going to be a optimization
problem so let's say the Chi Ches were
smaller here you're going to tend to
want to leak into the up into the
network in some way in order to minimize
the length of the curve according to
this this definition
and each of these points in your graph
correspond to a different region yes
this graph here yeah trying to do you're
trying to minimize over all regions
okay let me do this again so so suppose
I want to consider a sub region of
length L for this on sots
I want to get the best bound I can on
the amount of entanglement in that sub
region so let me fix the region L what I
can do is consider different curves
which cut out these two sites and you
don't care it include also other sites
yeah you'll get a weaker bound if they
included other sites just because the
entropy of one reduced density matrix is
bounded by any one that includes it so
fixing L I mean the sense in which you
could include extra sites is even if I
was only interested in these two I could
still make this curve in order to bound
it I'd added an extra site so I won't
get the best bound I could it would
still be a bound so you want to do is
find the curve with largest with the
smallest length which just includes and
closes the region in question yeah and
so the variational problem is if you
assign this weight to any curve you crop
to any link you cross to find the curve
with minimal length according to this
definition
this is like the the lattice
interpretation of the utopian doggy
formula and the problem is it's very
crude because this this is purely an
upper bound and what needs to be
understood is what the property of the
tensors are in order to make it more of
an equality rather than just a bound so
here we've shown that so long as the
network has some finite depth once the
region is large enough it always pays to
just leave go up the top of the network
so there's always going to be some
finite entanglement for the region so we
can't with that on thoughts get a
logarithmic violation so the idea of
your IVA doll was to consider a
hierarchical network that extends all
the way out to infinity
so let me make one more bad guess so we
know we need to go out to infinity in in
the new direction we also know that if
it's a CF T there should be some notion
of scale invariance so perhaps the
correct thing to do is just a tree
tensors
so the problem with this on slots is we
see that if I pick a region like this
it's actually very cheap to bound this
region I can just take a curve that goes
up and comes back down and I mean we can
see there's going to be arbitrarily
large regions which only will cross one
one cut so this doesn't actually contain
enough entanglement so the simple way to
fix it is I need to penalize moving up
through the network I have to make sure
there's new bonds I'm going to be
crossing so the way to do that looks
like this
so now the length of this curve let's
say all these had the same bond
dimension will depend on how far I'd go
up and that's going to cause it to curve
back down so in the simplest case where
I assign equal weight to all of them
the the number of bonds I mean across is
going to be logarithmic in the distance
here because as I go up all across about
log L bonds
as I go up and come back down so in this
case for a length of the curve gamma
including a region of length L will go
as long ago
now of course in this bound it doesn't
tell you anything about the possible
coefficient because we don't really know
the proper way to to weight the you
don't really have a way to assign the
correct pre factor there okay so this is
the sort of connectivity which would
give you logarithmic entanglement but it
turns out if we just use completely
arbitrary tensors here it's impossible
to do anything useful with the network
say if you want to put it on a computer
and actually compute properties of the
wave function so what get free Badal
proposed was that you can actually make
a vast simplification to everything
if these tensors have simple properties
in particular certain notion of
unitarity so the resulting on thoughts
is called the multi scale entanglement
or normalization nonsense
so the structure of the network is like
this there's two types of tensors
okay so this is sort of simplification
of this case there's actually less
vertical links ours are less horizontal
links but still because there's these
links that go like this as you go up
through the network unlike the tree case
you do cross bonds so you still get the
log violation of entanglement and what
he said was that these tensors had to
take a particular form so there's these
two to one tensors which are thought of
as coarse graining and then these are
two to two tensors which are the distant
Tanglers so the way coarse graining is
defined so these all called be is it the
property of this tensor is that it's an
isometry so this is V if I view this to
be the row and just to be the column
than Vivi dagger
so it's basically a projection operator
in particular as long as you think of it
as pushing states this way it's norm
preserving so this is the isometry
condition
so the second type of tensor
you and these are unit Ares new day
so this is called the disentangling step
and this is the core screening step so
let me explain why that that's gonna
simplify things so the key point here is
that because these are unit Aires and
isometry x' there's essentially a sharp
velocity of light in this network when I
add the on thoughts here if I twiddle
with something here it can propagate
arbitrarily far that way so there's not
really strict causality whereas in this
case because the network is sparser a
change here can at most flow like this
so let me say how that actually lets you
compute something so what gift free
showed was that if you don't oh yeah
yeah so let me just say the the
interesting thing that gift free showed
was that if you had the wave function in
this form and he provided a procedure to
find it giving the hamiltonian that it
actually encodes all the data of the CFT
due to this special structure so what
the idea is is that this network should
actually just be thought of as the
dilation operator of the CFT a lattice
version of it so if I look at the wave
function here it's gonna have say L
sites after one layer of this network
because of the coarse graining there's L
over two sites this has L sites that
says L over 2 and we can think of this
motion here as being or I can do it this
way this sort of renormalization step R
this is just a quantum operator taking a
Hilbert space on L sites to a Hilbert
space on L over two sites
so what the idea is is that our this
operator is the lattice version of the
dilation operator and the C of T so this
would be e to the I long to D this is
the generator of scaled transformations
and what one can show numerically and
I'll say how is that this appears to
actually be true and we know that if you
know the behavior of all the scaling
transformations you know the spectrum of
all the conformal weights in the theory
so the way we can test this is figure
out how if you take a local operator and
conjugate it by our how does that
operate a renormalize
so if I have some local operator why the
way it transforms under a dilation is to
shift it then I also get a rescaling by
the anomalous dimensional called Delta
Phi
so if i exponentiate this these these
are the same it's just the operator that
our that's our is gonna reduce the
dimension I'm confused by something our
hat looks like it's doesn't have a
kernel whereas our does
I think the way I'll think of it is our
goes from the the input would be in the
UV and the output would be in the I our
sweat even by reduced the input you're
wondering which sides the larger hilbert
space well I think it's a little bit of
a subtlety so to understand whether you
should think of this thing is being
unitary or being an isometry depends on
once we think about the lattice again so
you could ask suppose you have the
hilbert space of a ring of length L what
the dilation operator does is it relates
that hilbert space to the hilbert space
of a ring of length L over 2 now if you
don't consider it to be any cut off both
of them are infinite dimensional hilbert
space and you can actually think of the
two is being unitarily related when it
isn't unitarily related is when you
actually consider it as a lot of smaller
weathers it cut off so I think it's fair
to say in the continuum you can think of
this as being a unitary operation
ok so L o and L over 2 means suppose I
temporarily consider it to be on a ring
rather than an infinite line there's
certainly been a decimation of half the
sites which is what I'm invite L&L over
to I can buy I mean concretely
considered to be on a ring an
interesting question there a
the gravity way of thinking about it
really suggests that you think this is a
reduction in the number of degrees of
freedom as we flow in alternative
viewpoint where you basically spit out
lots of trivial spins as you as you move
in and think where this unitary
evolution is interesting as well there's
a paper by Carnegie suggesting that
those the number of those trivial states
keep track of how far in I am from the
boundary and I think if that viewpoint
is correct and there will be something
wrong in a way that we've been thinking
about this drop upon the gravity to
point it's very different from from the
RG viewpoint that we've had on this I
mean if I do want to think about this on
a ring saying a 1 plus 1 DC ft we can
say exactly what this operator does so
we know by the operator state
correspondence if I have a ring of
circumference L I can label all the
states you're an operator in the theory
and what this operation will do is in a
sense just do nothing it will just
directly relate the hilbert space of the
ring up circumference l 2 1 l over 2 but
there's just a one-to-one correspondence
between the states because they're
labeled by operators what's change is
when we know there's actually a physical
cut off the very very high weight states
here aren't really physical because
they're above the cutoff
our hit is a unitary aureus and what
well it depends on the point of view so
if if I do this on a finite ring it will
be isometry rather than unitary D D hat
well so I mean really D hat is only
meant to find in the continuum where I
can do this infinitesimally this mean
when you're starting to describe the
mirror which is a finite dimensional
okay so I think I'm not actually going
to do it in a continuum I'm always gonna
go by log 2 steps but the intuition for
what we should expect
I'm just motivating me an intuition for
what we should expect for how our
behaves
dimensional picture and density could
you say what these operators are there
and then we can yeah yeah so let me
consider yeah so I think the way to be
concrete is rather than talking about
our itself let's say what art does to a
local operator under conjugation
so
because of this definition let v denote
some like one point operator some local
operator localizing your X so I can ask
what happens when I conjugate by okay so
by way of motivation what would happen
in the CFT is because of this
commutation relation I will get
something like this
to the Delta
now the to here is just because I've
course screen by a factor of two okay so
this is the expectation if we know
something about CF t I can just say what
operationally it means given the
discrete tensor network so the
equivalent of my o is somewhat say to
site gate localized in a region so this
is oh and elsewhere it acts as the
identity so what I want to do to
implement this R is to conjugate by one
layer of the mirror so what that looks
like is
this is again a definition of an
operator on a lattice with half as many
sites and the key simplifying property
is the fact that these are isometry x'
and these are unitary x' so what it what
it means since this is our and this is
our dagger far away they cancel in pairs
because of the condition uu dagger
equals 1 all these cancel
what I'm left with is some sort of
impurity here in the identity far away
so what this map has done is it's taken
a tensor acting on a finite number of
sites to a new operator which acts on in
this case three sites so the merit
preserves locality in that when it
conjugates a local operator it turns
into another local operator and the way
one would extract from this what the
scaling operators are is to look
precisely for eigen operators of this
transformation so if you can find some
three site operator that under
conjugation returns to itself
that's the scaling operator in the
theory so I get free was able to show
numerically was you can actually carry
out that procedure given the use in
these he diagonalizes the operation of
conjugation by r and the the full
spectrum is actually the scaling up
spectrum of the CFT so that's why we
prove useful there okay I think I can
stop right there